racist monuments are being pulled down
streets are being renamed many former
colonial nations are facing a moment of
reckoning over the actions of their
forebears
today we look at how colonialism has
shaped our past in africa
how it is impacting our presence and we
ask
what needs to be done so that the future
looks different black people are still
trying to
fight for their rights and still trying
to have a space
not being second-class citizens the
colonialists
they they took everything
that could benefit africans
we as the african people we forgot well
i believe we forgot where we came from
hello i'm christy mundo welcome to dw
news africa
the world seems to be taking notice of
persisting symbols of racism and the
need to confront the legacy of
colonialism
in the u.s and the uk a number of
statues of
slave owners and colonialists have been
defaced or taken down in recent weeks
in belgium local authorities removed the
bust of king leopold ii
in the city of ghent and here in berlin
preparations are underway to rename an
underground train station because the
current name
is derogatory to black people
it may be a new conversation around the
world but not
in africa think back to south africa in
2015
when students at the university of cape
town successfully lobbied
for the removal of a monument to cecil
rhodes
another colonialist for weeks crowds of
students protested on the campus
rhodes statue was to them a symbol of
institutional
racism that they say persisted at the
university
and across africa people are fighting a
similar
battle our first report takes us to
southwest
cameroon where my colleague blaise eun
met
one activist who's been working for
decades
to erase tributes to colonizers
andre bless osama has made it his
mission to take down street signs
bearing names of colonial figures from
the past
today his target is charles de gaulle
the former french president
and world war ii leader in dweller
cameron's financial hub
many streets are named after
colonialists if someone wants to change
that
parish when you go to paris you don't
find a monument to the germans who
occupied it during the war
some parts of china were controlled by
the british but you won't find a statue
of a british person in china
so this should not be the case in africa
all societies have their heroes and
every nation
has its pride
[Music]
summer has been tracking down monuments
for the last five years
this statue of philippe luclear a french
world war ii general
is at the top of his list esama has
repeatedly toppled and beheaded the
general
and the government is tired of putting
him back up again
agents have a summer under surveillance
and affairs has been built around the
statue
to keep him away no no no no no
he's lucky he's protected by this fence
everything we say is backed by evidence
historical evidence is clear everything
that has been written about leclerc
is a way of paying homage to france
france
but we are not in france esama insta
wants to preserve the legacy of
cameron's own heroes
two years ago he commissioned the statue
of renowned footballer
at the moment there are more status of
french colonial figures in cameroon
than that of local legends this course
has come with a heavy price
for summer since 2015 he has been to
prison
every single year for putting down
monuments of french colonial figures
in cameroon like most young people in
cameroon
31 year old kamanu stella supports
summer
she visits him whenever he's arrested
and held in detention
our brothers sisters and parents fought
for us we have not recognized their
sacrifice
at the same time we're putting up
monuments to colonialists
i don't think that's right
is hoping his campaign will change
people's views of the past
by replacing symbols of colonialism
celebrating instead cameron's own
achievements
and a goal of advancing future
prosperity
[Music]
for many people the removal of racist
and colonial monuments
is an important step to erase painful
reminders of the past
but of course there is much more to do
because
colonialism continues to impact the
lives of people on the continent
in the present day and in many different
ways
our reporters in ghana south africa and
kenya took to the streets to ask people
how they felt colonialism affected them
today
i grew up in an education system that
made me myopic in terms of i think you
know sometimes
as a ghanaian i don't think i've been
that
creative or been that solution oriented
in finding solutions to certain problems
i can solve myself
but because of the way i have been
trained colonism makes africa in such a
big way that
it brought division amongst us as
africans as we now cannot come together
and see
eye to eye as africans because we now
regard each other as enemies
instead of us coming together with that
brother love and helping
each other built up personally i have
relatives in
burkina faso and mali but because of
colonialism
when i visit them i'm seen as a stranger
from ghana and not
a member of the family so my family is
so fragmented that it's difficult to
even connect with them
for me the family system has been broken
because of
colonialism a lot of our resources are
still owned by companies
from from outside so from from our
former colonial masters
and our governments are more interested
in inviting
those guys to come as external investors
and giving them
interests and you know tax breaks and
everything they can do
as opposed to seeing how we the locals
can be able to invest in our own
countries
we don't own our economies
so a number of examples given here of
how the past
impacts the present another issue
is one of disproportionate land
ownership on the continent
it's also a legal legacy of colonialism
between 1860 and 1960 settlers and
white-owned companies took
1.5 million square kilometers of land
from
indigenous people in southern africa
that's more than a third
of the land much of it was not returned
despite the formal
ending of colonialism in namibia for
example
white people own some 70 of the farmland
today but make up just
six percent of the population that's
despite
government attempts at land reform south
africa has
similar inequalities 72 percent of
commercial
agricultural land is in the hands of its
white minority
parliament there is working on a plan to
redistribute some of this land
but that's the situation as it stands
in kenya the talai and kipsigis people
are still
fighting for their land in 1902
british colonialists drove them from
their homes in the lush western
highlands
to make way for tea plantations last
year with the help of kenyan and british
lawyers they started a
collective effort to push the uk
government to account for
colonial colonial-era injustices at the
time
dw traveled to kericho to meet some of
the victims
here's their story
hardship and suffering has followed
ludea to teach her entire life
when she was just a child she was
separated from her family
together with thousands of talai and
kipsikis people she was expelled from
her ancestral lands
at 96 years old she still vividly
recalls
the trauma of that experience
i don't remember the date but the hour
we were chased away
was four in the afternoon i was so
frightened
my stomach started aching and i started
vomiting
[Music]
ludia's parents were forcibly removed to
so-called national reserves
making way for acres and acres of
profitable tea plantations
today they are owned by multinational
companies
ludia stayed behind to work on one of
the british tea estates
there she was repeatedly raped by her
employer who got her pregnant
when the white man as she calls him
attacked her for the first time
she was only 13 years old
there was nothing i could do he used a
lot of force to overpower me
i didn't understand what was going on i
was in a lot of pain
and i was crying a lot
when kenya became independent in the
1960s
ludia was left to fend for herself as an
outcast with three biracial children
and no money on land to live on today
she is one of more than one hundred
thousand victims
who are demanding that a united nations
special investigator
opened an inquiry into their plight
british soldiers expelled families from
their homes stole land and livestock
and committed gross human rights
violations all for the sake
of planting this crop the victims of
this land appropriation
say there is blood in the tea here they
want reparations for their maltreatment
and above all an apology for the crimes
committed
under the crown
the last survivor of one of the biggest
mass deportations to gwasi
that was 1934. many members of his
family died
he still hopes the complaint lodged with
un will compel the uk
to answer for its colonial crimes
i feel so much pain why are the british
delaying compensation for the suffering
and not giving back to us the land they
took away from us
until there's no one left to testify
the other old men have died i'm the only
one left to tell the suffering
of gwasi like kibore
lodia and her daughter hope should be
able to witness an
apology
if they ask for forgiveness we will not
refuse to accept
we will not refuse
that apology never came sadly ludia
chirotech has since passed away without
experiencing the return of her ancestral
land
or any other form of reparation the case
of the talai and kipsikis
is ongoing i'd like to bring in rodney
dixon
a british lawyer representing them mr
dickson
thank you for making time time is
ticking
for many of these claimants where is
this case at
the case is with the united nations at
the moment
but it's also with the un united kingdom
foreign office we have lodged the
complaint and case there
and taken it to the united nations to
act as
expeditiously as possible because every
day matters to those
who've been waiting so long for
acknowledgement and apology and
compensation
this lawsuit is against the uk
government
but the land is currently in the hands
of private companies
unilever for one how will all this come
together
well it is the uk government that is
responsible we say
uh because of the colonial past which
has
continued from successive government to
to governments it doesn't
get cut off just just because the
colonial period
ended the the damage that arose
should and and can still be compensated
now um but to the extent that the the
land is owned by others now
then they have to act to ensure that
they compensate persons properly or
where
their land is actually no longer being
used or not
being used to return that land it's
really a question of
getting around the negotiating table and
and hammering out
a constructive and positive solution
that can be done and for too long it's
been avoided
let us talk about that solution what
outcome are you pursuing here
the victims first and foremost
my clients want acknowledgement for what
has happened
uh and they want uh an apology many have
said who who are old
that they don't want to die without
hearing
that apology that that's the the main
thrust of
their claim i think that would apply to
any of us
who who were in their situation uh
beyond that
yes people do want compensation so they
can get on
with their lives and also where it is
possible
to restore land to to do that
this is not some kind of land grab
people have tried to paint it in that
way and demonize it
not at all far from it it's an attempt
a legitimate and rightful attempt to
get an acknowledgement for what has
happened in the past and compensation
that is
commensurate in the circumstances
mr dickson what are the obstacles that
stand in the way of cases such as this
one
and what needs to change
uh often the biggest obstacle is the
time that is passed
legislation is often in place as is the
case here to stop
actual claims being brought to to court
which
seems rather unfair i i think we
we would all agree that just because
time has passed doesn't mean
that they shouldn't be a remedy
especially when people have been trying
for
so long so there are time obstacles
uh but then frankly there's just the
obstacle of uh
those now who are in power and not
wanting to acknowledge
what has happened a concern that that
might open the floodgates to
to many historic injustices uh
and and that that can't be a reason
either we we say
there needs to be a true moral awakening
and recognition here and that can
readily be done and it will be to
everyone's
benefit this is in the interests of all
parties it's not one-sided
mr rodney dickson thank you for your
time sir
the chances of that moral awakening as
rodney dickson puts it appear
slim we reached out to the british
foreign
and commonwealth office and asked if the
uk government was willing
to issue a formal apology and offer
reparations to claimants
we received the following statement
while the fco understands the pain and
grievances felt by the capsigies and the
talai peoples of kirichou county
the fco does not accept liability
for the alleged violations
[Music]
looking to the future let's imagine that
all injustices were redressed and what
was taken was
given back would that be the end of the
story
for victims of colonialism or do we as
africans
have to do some work in ourselves i'll
be talking to a psychologist about that
in a moment but have a
quick listen to what others think
maybe we might want revenge but if we
really if we're talking about moving
forward and progressing
i don't think that's really going to
help we need to sit down and we need to
create our own blueprint
the change that we need in this
continent is really fundamental
and it's really really deep within
within us and it doesn't have to
come from somebody who has done
something uh
several several years ago because no
matter what if they
pay back they do whatever it still
exists in our mind
so i think the better way to go about
this is to move on from your mind and
then you know just
build up all the things that you want to
build my dream is to be free
economically
be free in all all aspects and enjoy my
life
for now i think that we owe ourselves
that to be able to change our mindset
it's actually we need to decolonize our
minds that's what people are suggesting
there
and it's a subject that's been addressed
by many great thinkers for example the
acclaimed afro-caribbean writer and
philosopher franz
fanon wrote imperialism leaves behind
germs of rot which we must clinically
detect
and remove from our land and from our
minds
as well but how how do you do that i'd
like to put that question to nonfundo
mujapi
she is a clinical psychologist and the
executive director
of the center for the study of violence
and reconciliation she is in
johannesburg
welcome to you know many people are off
the view
that the african mind is still colonized
how does a colonized mind manifest
itself
yeah so for me really it's not as much
the external stuff i know there's a lot
of talk about issues of
language what we were but it is the
internal
state of our mind it is about the
relationship that we have with ourselves
personally as african people
and their and how they need manifest and
how we interact with each other
because at the core of colonialism was
the psyche that says that because of the
color of your skin
you look less than the other you are
worthless
than the other or because of the color
of your skin you are better than the
other or you are with more than the
other
so at the core of a colonized mind is
the mind that think that
the value and the worth of an individual
is determined by how they actually look
and therefore you piss you then would
like to pursue a certain
way of being because you think that the
way that you are
is not good enough and you are likely to
then treat people that
look like you very similar to
those that had actually colonized the
people so for me
i always say that the work of
decolonialization is
really about at the core the undoing of
what does it
take to say you are wealthy as a human
being
and taking this thing that the color of
your skin and whatever that
represents then determines your worth
you know as you talked about that i
thought about some of the afrophobia
that we have on the continent just to
the point you made about how we
then treat other people in the same way
that the colonizers treated us
having said that then nom fundo how do
we decolonize
the mind
so i always say that at the core of
decolonization
is the work of the reclaiming of our
dignity actually i don't think it's even
just
reclaiming it's fighting for our dignity
and our wealth
the work that we need to do as the
african people
is i like what martin luther king said
he said at the core of our blueprint
we have to have this sense this
unshakeable knowing
that we are wasting that we are
significant
as human beings it is not about the
color of our skin
it is not about the car we drive it is
not the external things
that determine our worth because if as a
people we could
really so there's a lot of
transformation that we need to do around
just this
innate sense of not being enough of
worthlessness where we then use the
external things to try
and fit that in and be able to know our
wealth and
treat other people the same way that is
the greatest work
the negative messages we've been told
about ourselves
as as a people when we grow up some are
the voices of our parents some are the
voices of
the colonizers themselves and we have
now internalized them
as our truth we don't even question them
anymore so we have to really
question the things that we've accepted
as normal
and i think the other challenge that we
have is that
is when we are so asleep to how much
we've assimilated
and accepted this as truth and when we
get into position of power how we use
than whiteness
as the standard of our worth and we
haven't found ways of saying what is
a standard of being okay just as you are
as a human being not even as an african
as a
human being looks like
no fonda just looking to the future
what is your vision of how
an empowered african with a decolonized
mind
is uh if we're all in that state how
could the continent be better
in a sense
i think for me and an empowered african
would be an african who is absolutely
sure
of who they are that they don't need to
feel that they must prove themselves for
being here in the world
that by being human by being born into
this world
they belong to this world it is their
space to occupy
it's an african who is very clear about
their sense of direction
and don't feel that they either have to
excuse and be apologetic for who they
are
or that they have to constantly be
fighting to prove themselves to others
but they are so comfortable in their
skin they are so confident
in who they are they then treat other
people
with that same respect and they are able
to then pull up other africans
and make them see their worth inside of
them
for me that is an empowered person
that's nonfundo
mojave the executive director of the
center for the study of violence and
reconciliation in johannesburg thank you
so much rufundo
for that insight thank you
what does an empowered africa look like
to you
i'm keen to know so write in the
comments section or get in touch with me
directly my twitter handle
is at mundo 7 i look forward to hearing
from you
bye
you